كيف لا يحتفى بالحياه هي هنا حياه عائشه
الفتاه التركيه الخارجه الينا من تحت
الانقاذ
مثلها كتبت النجاه لذاك الطفل الرضيع
[موسيقى]
وللفتى ابن 13 اردجان
ولان في العمر بقيه تخرج الى النور سيده
سبعينيه حصرت بين انقاذ مبنى من طوابق عده
[موسيقى]
الساعات الطوال الثقال على المنقذين
ومنقذيهم قد تفضي اذا الى ما يهون المصاب
وفي وقائعك هذه حتما ما يبث املا في نفوس
من لا زالوا ينتظرون عوده قريب مفقود
واضح ان الامل القائم في مركز الزلزال
الاسوا في المنطقه منذ قرن تعززه امكانات
البحث والانقاذ التركيه والدعم القادم
اليها من الخارج
ليت الامر كذلك وراء الحدود الجنوبيه
يعلم السوريون في المناطق المنكوبه
بالزلزال ان ليس لهم غير الله كما قالوا
هدوما من سيلومون على جعل معدات الانقاذ
والاسعاف الحيويه حلما بعيدا المنال
لم نتلقى اي شيء عبر الحدود الى حد اللحظه
لا فرق انقاذ ولا تجهيزات طبيه ولا غذاء
بعد خمسه ايام من الزلزال اننا نحتاج الى
اغاثه غذائيه وعلاجيه وايواء عاجلا غير
اجل
لا ينشغل الناس هنا في الشمال السوري
المنكوب بالمسؤوليات التي تتقاذفها
الاطراف عن التقصير والتاخير
يبقيهم هنا الامل في ان ثمه انفاسا تحت
هذا الركام لم تنقطع
لكن العجز يتملكهم بعد الانتقال الى
عمليات البحث والانتشال فالخوض البيض تخرج
من الجثث اكثر مما تعثره على ناجين يمضي
الوقت ومعه تفرض الحكمه تحويل الاهتمام
كله نحو الناجين ممن شردهم الزلزال
[موسيقى]
اولئك بحاجه الى ايواء واعاشه وذاك وعد
اخر اخلفه كما يبدو جل الواعدين